this confident Mike's new girlfriend
trusting boy oh boy oh boy
I think a few people already here and
then she's you have to go over here
Omar each is having a really weird
stroke we're stuck in this stupid thing
you please let it out please hey I'm
just doing like Sam taught me other
people's private thoughts pretty nice do
not be a jerk my goodness
seems that someone has a little crush on
our good friend and dear class president
Annika 100 and what kind of sizzling
erotica my daughter Jessica be capable
of a machine I'm holding a letter
addressed to Mike
yeah to Lodi that's my mom
ah such an idiot maybe nosy Nancy you
shouldn't go nosing around in other
people's nostrils yeah you guys go ahead
I'm just gonna wait here for a bit see
who else is coming you mean Mike what I
mean you know whoever Sam your hands are
freezing
I know that
shouldn't be should be the other way to
once it's through Salinas you antigen
results a little persuasive okay that
makes you the [ __ ] none of those a nice
things yes yes weights and intelligent
people motivated ambitious active didn't
have a moment
definitely not gonna feel like a regular
party I mean
that's like oh my two monkeys a dick
from last time yes intelligent criminal
persuasive also means either [ __ ] but I
wasn't drinking and persuasive got like
three yeah like what the way you're
being you always get like this Michael
I'm just gonna lay it out on the latch
this whole weekend it's gonna see some
that has a rated one this is super
awkward and we all know it let's just
die no no I like you I hate you man
I get it I want to make this weird cool
good oh good you guys gonna make out now
oh my god see ya see ya
interesting character that guy I hope he
dies hey could you take these the rest
of the way
yeah sorry I just I really need to go
find her I totally forgot rubbish don't
let me get all the way up there and I
really don't think you should head back
down the trail by yourself seriously
it's cool it's getting dark
you're gonna protect me from it being
dark out the point nobody's gonna steal
it
Matt are you kidding me you can't leave
me alone for five minutes you really
think that little go just feels right
why can't just listen to me why are you
I'm just trying to be helpful if you
want to be helpful then you can help get
everything up to the lodge as quickly as
you can okay yeah I felt like she needs
to go fish
okay make an effort to make her dive or
the time comes the butterfly effect if
you haven't just something I can assure
you want to go anyway yeah but I feel
like maybe been assaulted maybe sign
documents maybe it's also know that
you're on trial itself who is this
actually he's someone I mentioned
criticism - actually I can't tell yet so
yeah academic inquisitive forthright and
we never teach the traits you merely
need to lock them all down wind that
moves me they'll be in the menu again I
guess you as if you go further into it
we'll just hand it over
yeah I think I like that series of
traits she knows though she might be at
one she's getting a little friendly
why seriously why do none of these
people and application date on their big
break up it's a pretty name would be
absolutely freezing that's the thing
that always gets the coldest scared you
a sort of but not like for real what are
you looking at we lost you could've got
me check it out I think he already told
you to take a look oh dear achingly
Slade it's busted I don't win but I also
know you around they didn't need [ __ ]
coming out what getting involved and
that clean on site I like the way she
was older about it she was like she was
like yeah actually nothing is ever just
nothing with him ever I don't know I
you deserve to see that
oh no no it's because he's late Oh what
do you mean well I was thinking that he
might have had feelings towards her and
then she went off with the other it was
Mike but then I realize it's probably
because she's sitting on mic which is
supposed to be one of these other
friends this is like that is the one
that statement that God is dating in
these days so this is Jess who's now
dating Frank rebook which I find pony
clubs on where's the gloves option yeah
they already fun to move into trouble
that's true
whatever come take me into custody
No
thirty minutes
it's vaguely dirty right now no hands
people all of your hands oh my god with
a shape yeah yeah yeah everyone except
yeah actually
quote and then other girl the one that
was kissing mind exam only so many
nights remember I've got to get so lost
I'll get it I'll get that this is some
other lobby
oh yes I think so someone's just arrived
Oh back to this guy it was a strange
time to do things we'll be able to do
that right and how are we well thank you
sir we're good it's so fun scary's
haven't yet yeah I'm actually interested
to find it out find out who it is to
change events or some cameras on what's
left this is all go straighten up pick
up my trash from the pages you will see
a set of pictures and symbols I want you
to identify which again which set
and we would you have me to say women
worry me but yeah you know what I'm
gonna be on the sidelines client hate
plants
and I put on hats but I don't know
whatever you want to do not mind I would
be worse than drowning I think but I
also don't like Heights too much
rather a snake snake and you probably
say that or neither
yeah I see me go but water snake yes
like tickling me dancing I find snakes
are my I don't know it's head pain I
just yeah I don't know I guess we don't
see you know and see done so it's not
unrealistic merely state knives like I
see it come to action maybe it's not
like initially conquer just make well I
mean I'd be more scared of saying yeah
clown
then North pretty freakin good on the
same skipper and on my clear doesn't
have a face on the seven to eight have
to face her more cool I'm not scared of
which I'm not really willing by eat up
oh okay sorry
you doomed very well okay big hands to
try to speed up okay so you don't one
fine uh definitely gone spider sorry uh
energy fix pilot needs to a big snake
needle gold gold be better actually
that's good scarecrows though like it's
gonna be moist and stickers on the door
and I'm utterly welded by earbuds things
to do and I like my favorite things and
now it's just to mix the west end of
goal yeah and we know don't bother at
all this is very interesting it's also a
terrible test this test is so
ineffective one stamp any of this
season's I don't feel like that wraps
around very well someone asked me stuff
I'm actually scared or no sinusitis
planes
planes so fun aid once again it's going
to become clear me to promise talking
invert
it's all the way are you done with you
you're dismissed
you know if I like him maybe he's a joke